well elsewhere wildfires are ravaging
parts of the western united states
forcing hundreds to evacuate their homes
the blazes have been exacerbated by a
record-smashing heat wave that has
killed over 50 people in the state of
oregon alone
scientists are pointing the finger at
climate change fueling a mega drought
that has turned
swathes of the u.s into a tinderbox
oregon's bootleg fire is the largest of
nearly
60 active wildfires currently burning
across the western united states
the extent of the blaze can be seen best
from above
it now covers an area larger than that
of new york city
forcing residents in its path to
evacuate their homes
this is my first wildfire and i'm gonna
tell you it is scary
it's enough to make you cry it's not to
make you sick to your stomach
because you don't know if you're going
to be the one that loses your house
or you sit there and you watch your
neighbor lose their house and there's
nothing you can do about it
many have had to take refuge in shelters
like this
while the fires have been fanned by an
extreme heat wave
with temperatures reaching 47 degrees
celsius
the heat alone has proven deadly
at least 54 people have died from hot
weather in oregon alone
over the last few weeks
the age range is from 48 to 97 with an
average age of 70 so
that affirms what we know which is that
older individuals
are at higher risk of heat related
illness the majority of them died alone
and without air conditioning scientists
offer little consolation
they see a direct link between climate
change
and heat waves that are fueling these
extreme
fires
and the fires are also raging in the
state of california for more i am joined
now by isaac sanchez he is a firefighter
and battalion chief at cal fire in
sacramento california uh thank you so
much for joining us
what is the situation like in california
right now
well it's very similar to what's
happening across the west uh elevated
temperatures
uh low humidities and of course a
receptive fuel bed that
that's ready to burn with with the
introduction of the smallest part
so given that i mean what what sort of
challenges are you now facing when
trying to extinguish
um you know fires and keep people safe
amid this extreme heat
so the primary uh challenge that we face
this time of year and we're facing it
sooner uh
in the year than we ever have in the
past um is the
the the rate at which these fires grow
and spread
uh that can now obviously face uh
present challenges not only for the
firefighters who are trying to
uh to put the fire out in the very in in
the first place
but it it's absolutely affecting the the
communities that
these fires are burning there uh and of
course you know causing the evacuations
that uh
that are clearly challenging our
communities
talk with us about i mean if you could
just put this into the broader context
for us um
you know we've seen this relatively
frequently in the past
years is it getting worse as the years
go on or is that just perception
well it kind of seems like it is getting
worse uh you know the the
the number of fires that we are
responding to is clearly growing that is
being
shown and proven uh through the data
that we collect and keep track of every
single year
but what's what's growing also is the
size of the fires they're simply getting
bigger than they ever have in the past
um most of the 20 biggest fires that
we've had uh
within the state of california um
historically
have happened within the last five to
ten years and that that is absolutely
concerning and a trend that we
absolutely would would
like to see reversed thank you so much
isaac sanchez as we mentioned you're a
firefighter battalion chief at cal fire
in sacramento california for taking the
time to tell us
uh more about the important work that
you're doing to try and keep people safe
out there so we appreciate it
thank you
let's get more insight we are joined by
carl friedrich schleichner he is a
climate physicist at humboldt university
in berlin and um carl friedrich i mean
we've just heard there we
spoke to that firefighter there in
california we're also you know not only
seeing in the u.s but also canada russia
spain extreme heat waves record
temperatures in many parts of the world
you know a lot of people point to
climate change
is this climate change or is this just
weather
well it's both but it's definitely
climate change one thing that we know
for sure
is that climate change is fueling
heatwave and making them
more severe and that's exactly what we
are seeing and also exactly what we can
link with scientific methods to climate
change and we are seeing
in particular in the case of the
northwestern heatwave in the u.s
and canada that we are not just loading
the dyes
and making extreme heat vapes more
frequent
we are also seeing unprecedented events
that wouldn't have happened without
climate change so we're not just
throwing more sixes if you want to say
so
climate change is making us throw sevens
and the impacts of this
are now being felt all over north
america
and part of your job is in fact you know
not just to assess what's happening
right now but also to
perhaps project into the future um when
it comes to the impact of climate change
what are you expecting now in the coming
years given the current situation
colleagues of mine just to keep at the
example have done an analysis
on the characteristics of this heatwave
and why this today
is indeed a very rare and extreme event
at a warming of two degrees above
pre-industrial levels such an event
could happen every five to ten years
so but that's by mid-century in a couple
of decades and i think it's illustrating
that the climate crisis is not some
something that's happening in the far
future it's something that's very much
upon us
i'm being based in berlin and instead of
saying we are leaving the american
sector maybe we should have signposts
everywhere that we are leaving the
civilization friendly sector with co2
concentrations in the atmosphere being
the highest in the last
three million years and temperatures as
we recall them probably the highest in
the last 12
000 years so in the time when humans
started to do agriculture
and civilization started to prosper i'd
like to ask you um
about the plans on the table to try and
you know combat
climate change um get emissions under
control the european union for example
says that it wants to drastically cut
emissions in the next decade
what do you make of that plan is it
enough
it's urgently needed but we do know the
plans that we have on the table are
insufficient
to achieve the one and a half degree
limit of the paris agreement and
these impacts remind us that we should
cut emissions as soon as possible and as
drastically as possible
in order to limit such future impacts so
while we see a lot of promising
developments in recent years also
with a change in the global political
landscape on climate action and a lot of
countries committing themselves
to achieve net zero emissions by
mid-century
much more is required in particular in
the next decade to slow down climate
change and get us on a track
towards achieving the paris agreement
carl friedrich schleichner
climate physicist joining us from berlin
thank you so much
thank you very much